[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
duh nothing nothing
you're the spider-man from YouTube
I'm not sealing wasn't it what are you
doing in my room mailing me and you said
we're gonna finish a test on her she
doesn't know why me mrs. Stewart knows
doesn't mean my super that's it Oh Tony
Stark are you an Avenger ah basically
this guy keep a secret secret why you
know what she's like if she finds hell
people try and kill me if assume that
she's not going to do this anymore ok ok
ok ok ok
I'll level with you I'll tell you if
it's a secret mr. Grayson has ever
happened to me I can't believe this hi
guys oh there we go
what are you hiding
Peter
I'm just kidding out okay
[Music]
what's up guys so to become an Avenger
oh they're like trials or an interview
do me a favor can't you just be a
friendly neighborhood spider-man just
stay close to the ground
you're the spider-man from you two can
you summon anomaly of spiders oh yeah no
do you know him - still a shield can I
try the suit on but uh the rich and the
powerful like Stark they don't care
about us the world's changing boys time
we change too these weapons are crazy
dangerous missing Peter forget the
flying monster guy there are people who
handle this sort of thing you legal
weapons Barry was a 230 you missed it
what if somebody had died I was just
trying to be like you I want you to be
better I'm gonna need the shoot back
well nothing without this suit if you're
nothing without this shoot then you
shouldn't have it I screwed up you need
to stop carrying the weight of the world
on your shoulders I want you to
understand helping anything
protect my family I know you know what
I'm talking about
so don't mess with
I'll kill you and everybody you love
a guy he's still out there I've just got
to do this on my own
just don't do anything stupid
all right yeah
[Music]
King
[Music]